Today for our experts
in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with doctor
Steven pinker on violence
and emotion. Dr Pinker's,
an experimental psychologist.
I'm one of the world's foremost writers
on language mine and human nature.
He's currently a Harvard College professor
and Johnstone family professor of
psychology as well at Harvard University.
His research on visual cognition and the
psychology of language has won prizes
from the National Academy of Sciences,
the world institution of Great Britain,
the cognitive neuroscience society and
the American Psychological Association.
Dr Pinker has also received
seven honorary doctorates,
several teaching awards at Mit and
Harvard and numerous prizes for his books.
The language instinct, how the
mind works, and the blank slate.
He's chair of the usage panel of the
American heritage dictionary and often
writes for the New York Times
time and the new republic.
He's been named humanist of
the year prospects magazines,
the world's top 100 public intellectuals,
foreign policies,
100 global thinkers and time magazines,
the 100 most influential
people in the world today.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview together with Dr Steven
Pinker. So thanks for speaking with us
today, Steve. It's great to have you here.
Okay,
good.
What I'd like to do is just start out by
asking you a little bit about what got
you interested in the topic
of violence and emotions,
sort of where did it begin for you?
Well,
I'm as a psychologist,
I'd be interested in human nature
and what makes people tick.
And it's a hard problem to avoid
because one of the questions that people
naturally ask about human nature is,
are we naturally violent or are we
naturally peaceful and cooperative?
And I think the answer to the to
that question is both in neither,
but a,
it's not a question you could avoid if
you're interested in big questions about
what makes us what we are.
And speaking of that,
I'd love to ask you some questions
about just what makes us,
what we are by asking you a bit
about your work on this topic,
looking at violence.
So you've recently published a book,
the better angels of our nature.
And in this you powerfully demonstrate
a somewhat counterintuitive but
remarkable decline in violence
in human society over time.
And I wonder if you could just provide
us with a little bit more about this
really fascinating, but again,
somewhat surprising finding for many.
Yes.
It's one of the reasons it's surprising
is we get our sense of the world from
the news.
And the news is about stuff that happens.
It's not about stuff that doesn't happen.
And since rates of violence
haven't gone down to zero,
there are always enough violent
incidents to fill the evening news.
They're the three things that
blow up people who get shot.
And because of the availability heuristic,
namely that we estimate risk according
to how easily we can recall vivid
examples,
our sense of how dangerous the world
is is out of whack with the actual
statistics. So this is an argument
that depends a lot on statistics. Uh,
for example,
rates of a death in tribal warfare
among a hunter gatherer and hunter
horticulturalist societies who live,
uh,
without the rule of law firm,
the state control have rates of death and
warfare that are far higher than those,
even in our worst,
worse.
So that's something about the
transition from a kind of tribal living.
The characterized a lot of
our evolutionary history
to modern society brought
rates of violence down. Another decline
occurred since the Middle Ages, uh,
were,
uh,
homicide statistics suggest that a
contemporary European has about one 35th.
The chance of being murdered,
Gerd as his medieval ancestors.
A third change was in institutionalized
a barbaric violent practices like a
torture executions burning somewhat at the
stake or disemboweling them, uh, alive.
Uh, the use of capital punishment for
our trivial crimes like poaching and
counterfeiting and bad robbing a store I,
the institution of slavery,
the institution of debtor's prisons
throwing someone in jail because they
couldn't pay back a debt.
Those were all abolished in a span of
about 50 years to the second half of the
18th century. Then more recently
since the end of World War Two,
uh, big powerful countries have
stopped waging war against each other.
Germany and France, uh, we know aren't
going to go to war and Russia and Poland.
Uh,
and that's very unusual in human history
in which states and empires were almost
constantly at each other's throats.
Uh,
more subtly in the 20 years since
the fall of the Soviet Empire.
It hasn't just been big,
powerful developed countries that
have stopped waging war on each other,
but more and more the rest of the world
has stopped fighting civil wars and the,
and,
and rebel conflicts,
rates of death across the world and
all forms of war have seen a bumpy
trajectory, but a downward
trajectory. Then finally, the,
the various rights revolution, civil
rights, women's rights, gay rights,
children's rights,
animal rights have all whittled
down various categories
of violence that used to
be with us for a, for Millennia.
Uh, domestic violence,
bullying, child abuse,
a lynching, pogroms,
um, uh, animals in blood
sports, gay bashing,
criminalization of homosexuality.
All of these are gifts of the various
rights revolutions of the last 50 or 60
years.
So those are the,
those are the empirical phenomena
that I sat out in the book.
So these are really interesting empirical
phenomena you're documenting and
people may wonder,
well,
why is violence declining and what role
could emotion play in this phenomena?
You know, are we becoming
a more prosocial, you know,
type of society experiencing?
And greater prevalence
or you know, uh, uh,
intensity of emotions like
empathy and compassion.
So does emotion play a role in this
decline in human violence? You think?
It absolutely does. Um, for one thing,
many categories of violence are,
are,
are emotional in the sense
that they are not just, uh, a,
a calculated predatory via
Ellen. Swear. We want something,
someone's in our way.
We get rid of them.
I mean that that is a big category of
violence and that you could consider just
purely cognitive or rational. But, um,
are there many other forms of violence?
Kind of what we think
of a senseless violence,
which is really driven by the passions
to men fight over a parking space and one
of them pulls out a knife and you've
got a body and a pool of blood.
A Nation feels that it is,
suffered a historic injustice and
conquers, uh, tries to conquer a few,
uh, rocky islands or more
patches of barren land, but
you can't grow anything on,
but it just a match
matter of national pride.
Or you have a sadism where a
serial killers or sometimes
entire societies bring
up the kids to wash a prisoner.
Uh,
Claude with iron hooks
are broken on the wheel.
None of these are particularly rational
in the sense of getting what you want.
So they were driven by emotions.
Then on the other side,
there are some kinds of violence
reduction that are purely cognitive.
We people figure out
violence is a bad thing.
Let's see if we could figure
out some way of reducing it.
But some of them are also emotional.
We feel greater empathy toward a larger,
uh,
category of living things.
So rather than just feeling bad about
our kids and cute little baby animals and
our best friends, uh, we
care more about strangers.
We find it less, um, fun
to see them. Disemboweled.
Uh, we find it painful in
fact to see them in pain.
A self control, I don't know whether you
want to call that an emotion or a, a a,
it certainly attracts with the emotions.
It,
it suppresses behavior that is
often triggered by the emotions.
And there a good argument that,
uh,
exercising our capacity for self control
is one of the ways that we reduce
violence. Somebody assaults
you, you may be mad as hell.
Well you may want to pull out a knife but
you count to 10 think the better of it
walk away and soft control
triumphs over emotion.
So it's really interesting and I mean
this begs the question of how we can
continue to foster these better angels
and sort of work towards promoting,
you know, ultimately the a
violence free society in many ways.
What recommendations would you have
to continue pushing this trend towards
decreasing violence and perhaps
greater empathy and compassion?
Uh, I think that a greater empathy and
compassion are, are good things up.
I don't think they are
enough, uh, because I,
I kind of doubt that you could really
get a person to empathize with all 7
billion people on earth. I mean,
no one has the emotional energy.
You get compassion fatigue and it
better not depend on, on that. Uh,
also there cases where empathy is
not such a good thing. Um, when,
when we talk about corruption
in the developing world,
what we're kind of talking
about is empathy in domains
where it shouldn't apply.
Like you give a job to your a knucklehead
brother-in-law because you feel bad
for him, uh, or your or your best friend.
You pay your best friend
out of a sense of gratitude.
We call that cronyism and nepotism.
It is driven by empathy as opposed to say,
giving a job to a perfect stranger.
How cold hearted is that?
But of course it is what you do
if you follow the rule of law,
which will ultimately make everyone
less violent than if it's one,
a clan of blood relatives fighting for
the perquisites of power against another,
each one empathizing plenty
within their own own clan.
So it's not to knock empathy, but it
isn't enough. You also need rule of law.
I think you need a, a, a government
that will penalize aggression,
that will not only make individuals, I
think the better of committing aggression,
but it calms them down because if they
know that their enemies are penalized by
the government, they don't have
to develop a belligerent, macho,
bad-ass stance to a
credibly assert deterrence.
So good institutions,
rule of law,
a democratic society
with a civil liberties,
but an effective police force
and bad judicial system. Uh,
certainly anything that expands empathy
such as cosmopolitan experiences,
you travel,
you read the words of others,
you're made aware of what life is like in,
at different times and places and
among people who are unlike yourself.
Also just the, the spread of, of reason,
knowledge of history, knowledge of, uh,
what kind of violence reduction
measures have worked in the past,
the setting aside of violence as a,
a problem to be solved rather than
as always a contest, uh, that,
that you have to win.
And finally taking advantage of our
sense of trade exchange fairness.
The idea that you can do
business with people, uh,
in an evolutionary psychologist
would call it reciprocal altruism.
When you trade favors with
people, you're bound to them. Uh,
they're more valuable
to you alive than dead.
You have ways of getting what you want
other than through via woods need me by
exchanging it for
something that they want.
So the cultivation of networks of
reciprocity I think has been another
historical development that
has reduced rates of violence.
So I think those are really all important
suggestions for thinking about how we
can continue to foster a society
where we see violence on the decline.
And so I wonder, although empathy may
not play, you know, the major role here,
when we think about what role can,
you know the study and understanding of
emotion play as we look forward into the
future, where do you see the
most important next steps here?
Well,
certainly expanding some of the things
that have worked in our society to other
that are, uh, have some catching up to do,
particularly when it comes to the
rights of women and gay people and, uh,
children. Um, so the,
the idea that you don't throw pink gay
people in jail, let alone execute them.
Uh, we kind of, we kind of won that battle
that's not no longer alive issued here,
but it is a live issue in a
lot of it large part of the
world. The idea that, uh,
you don't try to settle scores
of national humiliation that uh,
our country, our, our race, our
religion has been humbled in the past.
We have to get our revenge.
And again,
getting people away from that tribal
group against group mindset toward a more
individual, a human
rights mindset. I mean,
we wouldn't really counts are men,
women and children and their happiness
groups are kind of abstraction to
concentrate. And this
relates back to your, your,
your emphasis on empathy
to think of the individual,
the actual thing that feels pleasure and
pain as opposed to the abstraction of
the group is one of the big developments
that we've enjoyed in the west and that
the, um, uh, the rest of the world
could profit from a longterm.
So when we think then looking ahead
with some of the suggestions that you
offered and especially the students who
may be the next generation of conducting
these kinds of studies or
investigating these areas of inquiry,
what advice would you give to future
students who are thinking about embarking
on a study of emotion as it relates to
violence or just trying to understand
violence more generally?
Certainly to uh, appreciate, uh,
both the dark side and the
bright side of human nature.
I think a lot of psychology has tried to
paint a, a, uh, kind of Sunday school,
Pete Picture of human beings as
naturally peaceable and cooperative.
And while I, uh, I wrote a book
about how we do have that side,
we wouldn't need that side if we also
didn't have a lot of really nasty,
ugly motives.
And I don't think psychologists should
avert their gaze from the dark side of
human nature.
We can only,
we can only hope to control it if we
understand that the other is to take a,
an evidence based approach to violence.
It's often a topic of moralization.
We all deplore violence,
but how much do we understand about what
in fact actually increases or decreases
it? There I came across a lot of
cockamamie ideas that are why we held,
but for which there's no evidence and
some things that are not so obvious that
turned out to be big
producers of violence.
So we should have an open minded
empirical evidence based mindset to
understanding violence.
Well, thank you so much for
joining us again today. Steve.
It's a pleasure to speak with you.
My pleasure.
Thanks for having me on June,
and this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Steven Pinker
from Harvard University.
Thank you again.